welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who's always dribbling and this
video we're breaking down space jam a
new legacy
the movie feels like ready player poo
and it's absolutely filled to the brim
with easter eggs product placement
and callbacks to the greater warner
brothers library in this video we're
going to be going over the best of the
best and getting nothing but net
as we'll be pointing out every single
one of them that we could find
was a bit soul destroying but full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the movie yet then i
highly recommend that you check out now
if you think the video is a slam dunk
then please smash the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe if you're
a baller like me
or so my gran says now with that other
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into space jam a product
placement
okay so the opening of both space jam
and a new legacy mirror each other quite
a lot
both have big father and son moments in
which a paternal figure influences their
son's actions throughout the movie
lebron sun dom ends up designing a game
that becomes pivotal to the plot
and over the film the father learns to
appreciate his son's interests
the credits sequence also uses career
highlights of lebron playing
which is somewhat similar to the opening
montage that was shown at the beginning
of space jam
for michael jordan again it's like
poetry
they rhyme now young lebron can be seen
playing a looney tunes game on the game
boy
which is something that i actually owned
because i'm old as [ __ ]
now cut to the warner brothers server
room and we're introduced to algae
rhythm
aka algorithm
great easter egg this video has been so
bad so far it gets better though i
promise
now he refers to lebron as king and
according to the website
babynamespeedia.com
the name is of african origin and it
pulls from lebron
which also means king the nickname king
james is something that the player has
carried with him since high school
and it's a nice meshing of the two later
on algae calls dom
a prince which is clearly a nod to his
father's nickname
and all ties together into this legacy
idea interestingly warner bros actually
tried to create an ai that would predict
whether a film would be successful or
not
and i kind of feel that algae rhythm is
sort of playing on that too
in sarah silverman's office which i'm
just calling her that because i have no
idea what her character name is
we can see several names when she opens
her emails
these are actually the producers and
crew for the film including clark santon
and martin g whose subject line reads
film script
what scripture was it just a list of
films now behind her in the office are
posters for two of warner brothers
multi-billion dollar movies which
include aquaman and joker
speaking of posters when we cut it dom's
room we could also see one for the
mighty zango
this was illustrated by a brazilian
artist named hugo canuto
who reworked several comic book covers
to include figures from the candomboli
religion
you can find a lot of these online and
they look absolutely amazing
we can catch several more movie posters
including scoob
teen titans go to the movies the matrix
tom and jerry
birds of prey aquaman and the suicide
squad
during algae rhythms presentation we can
also catch several more properties from
the studio
including the original space jam the
mask batman 1989
dunkirk joker the matrix batman begins
the flash
charlie and the chocolate factory
inception and harry potter
in this room there are also several
statues including dot from the
animaniacs
and marvin the martian there's also the
line from the wizard of oz
batman and gizmo from gremlins algae has
marked up lebron in several properties
including batman
and we see the sports star show up as mr
freeze this is riffing on the animated
series version of the character
and it's an ice inclusion that makes me
wonder what it would be like
if we got a cool update to that show
next we catch a game of their own scene
that's better than season 8
as well as a harry potter quidditch game
quidditch was of course the main sport
in that universe
and lebron can be seen with this snitch
showing that he's won the game for his
team
much like how king james has many times
after dom is sucked into the server
verse
lebron says one in the matrix hell which
is not only a note of the matrix
but it's also one of the worst lines
ever put to film
moving on algae rhythm appears as a
giant head and he towers over dom and
lebron
whilst referring to himself as the great
and powerful this is actually a nod to
the wizard of oz in which the wiz 2
appeared as a giant head
and he called himself the exact same
thing the emerald city verse can also be
spotted throughout the movie
and you may notice the giant green
castle at several points before he send
into the server verse we get a display
with several of the worlds on it
including hogwarts
neptune orbit city from the jetsons
gotham bedrock from the flintstones
westeros from game of thrones and
hundera from the thundercats as well as
their mascara from wonder woman
lebron is sent across the server verse
and he flies past
westeros world like west's world take
having that
casablanca and a model of hogwarts which
has fireworks going off
this is known as the nighttime light
show and it's appeared throughout
several of the harry potter movies
there's also the model for the jetsons
amongst there and what i think might be
krypton from the original superman
movies
there's also bedrock which is flying
around in the background
from here he whizzes past the emerald
city before journeying into a black and
white kansas
the both of which are of course from the
wizard of oz next
is the matrix and we can make out the
nebuchadnezzar on the left-hand side
as well as red and blue pills finally he
lands in the looney tunes verse but
before getting there
orange rings fly up to greet him and
these pull from them that's all folks
ending that the show is famous for
james creates a nike logo in the ground
and also says that he's shorter than
kevin hart
who yeah why why you got a dunk on him
like that eh having that
now throughout the world we also see
several acme products
and these are of course from the
fictional corporation acme
that pretty much sells all of the things
in the looney tunes world
we later learned that they've been
supplying tnt to bugs which is a double
entendre
as he says they still get it there and
tnt is the name of a warner's media
channel
amongst this landscape is the village of
speedy gonzales
as well as a theater sign for the
singing frog who featured in several
looney tunes cartoons there's also a
bond for foghorn leghorn
and a theater which has several posters
of bugs bunny specials
lebron comes across some posters hanging
up which alternate between duck season
and rabbit season
they're ripped down sequentially which
is a nod to the looney tunes episode
rabbit fire
in which both bugs bunny and daffy duck
were trying to avoid being hunted
lebron hugs bugs obviously calling back
to simpler times
when he just used to play video games
bug stresses him up as alma fudd
and he changes his own appearance
slightly to look a lot like the big
chunks meme
he then gives james a haircut and this
moment has several easter eggs in it
firstly is the fact that this is a nod
to the shop which featured lebron james
and was set in a barber shop
next is the fact that there have been
several episodes of the looney tunes in
which bugs disguised himself as a barber
in here we see several pictures of other
characters including elmer fudd
and yosemite sam the former has shaving
cream and fruit on his head
and this is a reference to a famous
moment from the cartoons
in which bugs drop them there they head
to sam's saloon
named after yosemite sam and we can
catch even more characters in a photo
behind the bar
including foghorn leghorn this location
might be a nod to the bugs bunny rides
again short
which featured a saloon and it had an
appearance by yosemite sam
buggs says that everyone has left and
outside the saloon we can see that he's
turned a cactus into wiley coyote
and a watermelon an apple into the
roadrunner more than the martian shows
up
he flicks through the settings on his
gun and we can see that one has
charles ray on it which could be a
reference to the soul singer ray charles
go to the algae bar and we see the
villain dressed up as steve jobs
whilst the location itself is similar to
the apple shop
these are nicknamed the genius bar which
the g could stand for
and again we've got some top-notch
writing in this film
now kurta lebron and bugs traveling
through space and we see a planet for
the maltese falcon which starred
humphrey bogart
this 1941 noir film is still considered
one of the best of all time
much like how space jamming you legacy
will be regarded for several years to
come i'm sorry for
for taking the make of it i actually
thought this movie was all right if i'm
being honest
it wasn't terrible it wasn't great but
it's a kid's movie
and i'm gonna lay off it from now on now
the ship itself is clearly pulling from
star trek iconography
including a captain's log delivered by
james t bunny
which is of course playing on james t
kirk from the shows and films
on the front of the ship we can see the
alphanumeric code a113
which you may know for its appearance in
several pixar movies over the years
it actually calls back to a specific
classroom number that many of the
artists from pixar studied at
on a whiteboard james writes down
several character names including
superman
king kong trinity from the matrix and
also batman
lebron says he could have used superman
and this may be a nod to shaquille
o'neal
who not only had the nickname but is
also someone that lebron played
with lebron is placed into hufflepuff
which is of course from harry potter and
it's the worst house
but at least he seems happy they then
travel to dc world and we can see
several nodes to the comics and shows
here
and the planet is split into two with
gotham being on one side
whilst metropolis is on the other the
former is shrouded in darkness to show
its more shadowy side
whereas the latter looks bright and
colourful in the sky we can see the bat
signal
as well as blimps flying around gotham
and these of course appeared at several
points in the animated series
interestingly you can also catch the
watchtower satellite floating above the
planet
and this was the base of operations for
the justice league
there's also the daily planet i think
that this scene is probably my favorite
in the entire movie
the entirety of metropolis is styled to
look exactly like how it did in the 90s
animated superman show
and we even catch a glimpse of clark
kent at one point before he appears as
superman
amongst the people waiting at the train
station are commissioner jim gordon
selena kyle dick grayson and jimmy olsen
bugs bunny becomes batman lebron becomes
robin
and daffy duck becomes superman i think
the ladder especially is a nod to when
the character
has appeared as him throughout several
cartoons and at one point when i was
growing up
there was even a happy meal toy of this
the batmobile interior looks similar to
the 1966 version
and this scene is filled to the brim
with easter eggs we can also see several
stops including atlantis
and an orphanage the former is of course
the home of aquaman
and the latter is rumored to be
appearing as a set piece in the upcoming
mat reeves batman movie
they fly through the batman animated
series universe and we can see the
iconic red sky as well as more of the
police blimps
there's also atlantis and the fortress
of solitude
here you can catch a big giant key and a
lock and this was actually so heavy that
only superman was capable of lifting it
so only he could enter the location on
board the train we can catch porky pig
wearing similar clothes to jimmy olsen
and amongst the passengers are what
appears to be alfred from the animated
series
as well as lois lane and what i think
might be dr harleen quinzel
aka holly quinn these are all from the
animated show universe and we're joined
by several of the other characters from
these shows including aquaman
batgirl green lantern and flash from
here we go to mad max to get the
roadrunner and yeah this is a pretty
cool scene as well
we see wiley coyote hold up a sign that
says witness me
which is something that the followers of
a mortum joe did in the film before
ending their lives in a blaze of glory
as coyote can't talk he just holds up a
sign in a
nice little bit see i'm being overly
nice now now next we jump to the austin
powers verse
to see that mini me is now elmer fudd
and learned that sylvester has been
shaven to be mr pickles with
kurt to casablanca to see that yosemite
sam has replaced the character of sam
from that film
from here taz is dumped on the
windshield and we see that this is
carried out by rick and morty
the latter of which complains that he'll
never erase what he's seen from his
brain
same as i feel about this movie i
suppose but from here we go to westeros
world
to see foghorn leghorn with bleach
blonde hair riding the back of a dragon
similar to daenerys from that show next
we get a scene with speedy gonzales and
granny from the looney tunes
which is shot to be very similar to how
the opening of the matrix plays out
bugs is dressed exactly the same as
morpheus whilst lebron takes on the role
of neo
even down to the gun holsters and jacket
that he wore in the lobby scene
throughout the film granny ends up doing
a lot of neo's moves
and at one point lebron even refers to
her as the one
which was his nickname in that movie go
to their mascara for a comic book
panel-esque world
in which we see lola bunny carrying out
the trials that will allow her to become
an amazonian
this scene feels like it's ripped right
out of the opening of wonder woman 1984
and it involves lola using the lasso of
truth to save her friends
rosario dawson is the voice behind
wonder woman and not gal gadot
however dawson has voiced her in several
cartoons and
animated movies over the years in space
we can see a sign that says
tune world is four three two pass x away
and a parsec is a measure of distance in
astronomy
but in star wars lucas got it wrong and
thought that it was a measure of time
this is why han boasted about the
millennium falcon completing the kessel
run in 12 parsecs
and again it's like poetry now next
really bad video next they make their
plans and bugs dresses up as mc hammer
which is a joke you'll get if you're as
old as i am the characters wear their
classic toon squad jerseys
which the group also wore in the
original space jam film
rg rhythm says they're alive which is
clearly riffing on frankenstein
saying it after creating his monster
next we get the basketball game which
gonna be completely honest this is why i
feel so dead inside
with this video as it killed me a bit
when i was writing this script
there's an absolute ton of easter eggs
here but we're gonna be going through
them all
to point out every single crowd member
that we could find
now firstly our hannah barbara cartoon
characters including captain caveman
the flintstones yogi bear scooby doo and
the mystery machine
jabba jaw penelope pit stop and mckiller
gorilla
outside of these are also the likes of
the iron giant king kong who jumps in
with an airplane that attacked him in
his movie
the great gonzo from the flintstones
motley who tries to hit him
a quidditch team a yeti from smallfoot a
game of thrones dragon
the night king mr freeze gremlins
thundercats the agents from the matrix
the flying monkeys from the wizard of oz
the penguin the 1966 penguin the
spartans from 300
the nuns from the conjuring several
jokers including the jack nicholson one
and the 1966 version
we can also catch one of the joker's
goons wearing the classic leather jacket
that he and his forces had in the 1989
movie
with his logo placed on it next to the
giant we can also see a castle with evil
scientists on it
and this is where gosma was created
there's also
none from superman 2 as well as
pennywise
and fans of this channel will know that
i'm known for doing a video on
every time pennywise was hidden away in
the background of a scene
racked up millions of views and made me
a worldwide superstar
internationally renowned idiot i just
want to let you know i've also went
through space jam bit by bit
looking for every single pennywise
hidden in the background of a scene
and yeah there's there's one there and
there's there's one there so yeah
thank you for all your support there's
also morpheus and baby jane from what
happened to baby jane
which bit of an obscure reference for a
kid's movie on top of this there's the
mask
and the jukes from a clockwork orange
which were weirdly allowed to be in this
movie
whilst pepe le pew wasn't zorzo dorothy
and the wicked witch of the west from
the wizard of oz
as well as voldemort two catwomen some
monty python characters
trinity will smith from wild wild west
space ghost and the war boys from mad
max
in addition to this we can't catch
batman and robin and yeah
thank god who made it through that scene
as it ended me a bit inside
there's also the nerd looks from the
space jam movie and we almost get
michael jordan
but it's michael b jordan deep down i
actually really respect him for getting
paid for having a similar name to
michael jordan
and just shout out this guy for making
money off this you've gotta hand it to
him
now lebron also drinks water in the
locker room which could be another the
first film
in which michael motivate the looney
tunes with his secret formula that was
actually just water
he also writes the names of his family
members on his shoe
which is a pre-game ritual that the
athlete does in real life
now though i'm not 100 on this amongst
the crowd i think there might be a troll
from lord of the rings
and what could be in mind from the
batman 1989 movie
now the goon squad are also playing on
their real-life player nicknames
these include the brow chronos arachnika
white mamba and wetfire at one point
lebron is knocked out and birds circle
his head
which we can see are tweety pie
typically this was used in the cartoons
to show when someone was stased out
at one point we can see a back to the
bucket license plate which is using the
same font as the back to the feature
logo
the delorean even drives in front of it
beforehand
and it's a nice little easter egg just
don't tell anyone that warner bros don't
own this franchise
you also get bugs bunnies wild world of
sports which is a reference to the tv
special of the same name that he carried
out
could to porky pig doing the best rap
battle verse of all time
and we learn his nickname is the
notorious pig which is of course playing
on the notorious b.i.g
a rapper from the 90s when they start
losing algae ends up throwing a chair
which is actually a nod to a real-life
basketball game
namely when bobby knight did it during
one in 1985.
the author says king kong ain't got
nothing on me which is another when
denzel said something similar in
training days
which i won't repeat in its full context
because there's probably kids watching
hilariously king kong is there any i
actually
wanted you to win against godzilla bro
you know you know what i'm saying now
bugs bunny says
that's all folks a catchphrase of the
looney tunes
and he also mentions taco tuesdays to
lebron who has often said this on his
instagram
lebron even hosted a taco tuesday pop-up
restaurant
and he tried to copyright the term
though this was denied
anyway that's all the easter eggs i
could find in the film and obviously let
me know below if there's any i missed
i'm sure there's also a lot of other
videos out there like this by now
and i started writing this on the
weekend so just go over to their video
yeah watch it
write what i missed from theirs in the
comments and me and you
we'll just pretend that we phone them
yeah don't tell those other video guys
now as a thank you for doing this we're
actually running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the film
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you're on the meals to watch them
make sure you check out our breakdown of
all the easter eggs in black widow which
will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the full film and
pointed out everything you missed and
how it ties into the comics
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for saying through the video
i've been paul this has been exhausting
but i'll see on the next one take care
peace